today on the matt walsh show leftists
are fighting passionately to defend the
profit margins of the pharmaceutical
industry even as big pharma uses an
entire generation of children as lab
rats also federal officials hunt for the
murder of a dolphin while letting the
murderer of five infant children off the
hook plus an msnbc analyst explains why
it's a threat to free speech to allow
people to say whatever they want on
social media and a democrat candidate
for congress aborted her child to save
the planet finally in our daily
cancellation iohan omar is upset because
christians were singing on a plane how
dare they we'll talk about all that and
more today on the matt walsh show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you know a good sofa uh not only is
really comfortable and great but also it
can change the way your room looks and
feels if you've been listening to the
show for a while you've probably heard
me talk about helix mattresses helix has
left the bedroom now and they started
making sofas they just launched a new
company called all form and they're
already making the best sofas we've ever
seen so what makes an all form sofa
really cool for starters it's the
easiest way that you can customize a
sofa using premium materials and at a
fraction of the cost of traditional
stores you can pick your fabric the sofa
color color of the legs sofa size and
shape to make sure it's perfect for you
and your home they've got arm chairs and
love seats all the way up to an eight
seat sectional so there's something for
everyone and you can always start small
and buy more seats later on if you feel
uh that you want your all form self to
grow and change with you when you move
all form sofas are also delivered
directly to your door in the past if you
wanted to order a sofa you would have to
hire somebody to come and assemble it in
your home or break your back trying to
put it together yourself all form has
simple quick assembly that where there's
no tools even needed it's as simple as
that and if getting a sofa without
trying it in store sounds a little bit
risky don't need to worry you get a
hundred days to decide if you want to
keep it and all form is offering 20 off
all orders for our listeners at
allform.com
walsh so to find your perfect sofa check
out allform.com
walsh
over the past couple of years we have
watched as some of the great myths of
modern american leftism have been
exposed there's been a great unmasking
which ironically began around the time
when everyone started wearing masks one
of those myths which we discussed last
week is that leftists hate the police
that they're anti-cop it turns out that
the disdain for law enforcement is
really quite situationally based because
it all depends on circumstance
they will of course call for a cop's
head on a platter and start chanting all
cops or bastards and all the rest of it
if a police officer shoots a black
suspect even if that suspect is a
violent criminal who's shot while in the
process of trying to kill or injure
someone
anyone viewing the reaction to such
incidents in a vacuum
may erroneously conclude that the
protesters just hate police in general
but as we've seen that hatred does not
extend to the police officer who shot an
unarmed woman in the capitol building
nor does it extend to the coved gestapo
harassing soccer moms from bringing
their kids to the playground during
lockdowns etc
they're only they're only anti-certain
cops in certain very specific situations
outside of that they're generally
willing to give police an extraordinary
amount of leeway
in a similar way we have seen
that the american left are not
as they've been previously accused
a bunch of anti-corporation rich hating
socialists
now it's more accurate to say that
they're anti-certain corporations and
certain rich people but on both counts
the list is diminishing rapidly as there
are fewer and fewer corporations and
rich people remaining who who have not
bent the knee to left-wing orthodoxy
the ones who have demonstrated their
fealty to the leftist cause can expect
to be vociferously defended by the very
people who had in the past been labeled
anti-corporation
just look at how the left has become
valiantly to the defense of disney
pretending that
one of the largest corporations in the
world is a victim of right-wing cancel
culture
in fact even when they go after the few
remaining rich people who have not bowed
to them and there's only a few
they're usually attacking that rich
person on behalf
of and in defense of other rich people
so look at how they've taken the side of
the twitter corporate board against elon
musk
the twitter corporate board who by the
way together own almost no shares of
twitter i think once jack dorsey leaves
the board he's got two percent he's the
you know founder of twitter and he's
going to be gone in a few months and
when he's gone
like combined i think they have one
percent or two percent all of them
so they have almost no financial stake
in the company yet have claimed the
rights to make decisions against the
economic interests of its actual
shareholders and without allowing the
shareholders to have a say
the american leftist with his democratic
principles sees no problem with this
arrangement because he hates elon musk
not because elon musk is rich but
because elon musk is rich and not
leftist
and then there is the left's
relationship with
the pharmaceutical industry
now if there are any corporations in the
entire world who warrant extreme
skepticism and constant criticism
it's big pharma
i mean we live in a country plagued by
an opioid epidemic
addiction epidemic and that epidemic has
been largely driven not by drugs pushed
by dealers on the street but by drugs
made by the pharmaceutical industry and
prescribed by doctors who themselves are
riddled by financial conflicts of
interest
and yet the leftist goes to war to
protect this industry's bottom line
bottom line perhaps most notably
fighting on behalf of moderna and pfizer
by pushing for the government to require
americans to use their products
and that's a push that isn't over by the
way just this past weekend dr ashish jaw
who's uh biden's covet advisor appeared
on meet the press and suggested that the
white house may yet still impose a
vaccine mandate for travel listen
you were an advocate of a vaccine
mandate uh when you were on the other
side of of this
uh in your
private capacity here is that something
that can be implemented uh vaccine
mandate for air travel
um that's a really good question i mean
i think you know when i was uh i have
always believed and certainly the early
days of the pandemic once vaccines
became available i thought it was very
important to get as many americans
vaccinated as quickly as possible and
mandates worked
mandates do work
we are in a different position now
obviously with more than 220 million
americans vaccinated 100 million people
boosted
and so we really have to ask ourselves
what is the role of mandates moving
forward and we're going to need to
assess each of these
individual situations differently
now there was never any good reason to
have a vaccine mandate for travel or for
anything else
there especially is no reason for it now
two years later when almost everybody
has moved on from the coved thing we're
not doing covet anymore i don't know if
if the good doctor ja realizes that
but then again that's easy for me to say
i'm not a pharmaceutical executive
there's still plenty of reasons for them
to want mandates billions of reasons in
fact
the mandates are great for big pharma's
profit margins
and speaking of big big farmers profit
margins nothing over the past couple of
decades
has done more to help them in that
regard
than the invention of gender affirming
care for children the pharmaceutical
industry is carrying out
medical experiments on kids
making billions upon billions of dollars
doing it
while the left circles its wagons around
these mad scientists
and insists that that we must not even
ask questions about it
much less criticize
just hand your kid over
and let the medical industry do whatever
it's going to do
don't question it that's transphobic
there are today 300 so-called gender
affirming clinics offering so-called
therapy and so-called medical treatment
to kids in the united states not long
ago there was only one or two
not long before that there were none
now there are 300
but the med the middle medical industry
saw the market
saw the profit opportunity took
advantage
now millions of kids are being dosed
or being put on the path to being dosed
while big pharma rakes in billions
and sends its lackeys out to shield them
from criticism
one such lackey is a guy named dr jack
turbin
he's a child psychiatry fellow at
stanford medicine
and also by the way a soulless monstrous
hellspawn who has made it his life's
work to feed as many kids as he can into
the big pharma wood chipper um a few
days ago he tweeted a common lie that we
frequently hear
from the big pharma [ __ ] on the left
this is what he tweeted he said
puberty blockers temporary reversible
are more benign than going through a
puberty that can't be undone if you
can't see that then you really need to
reflect on your biases and whether you
consider trans people at all when you
form your opinions
yes the um
think about that for a second a drug
chemicals
being put into a child's body
those that drug is more benign
than the natural processes of your
child's body
a drug is more benign than just natural
growth
and this is the lie that has consigned
many children and will consign many more
to a nightmarish fate
the lie that the chemical castration
drugs are temporary and reversible
it's not true
it's it it is a lie
and the people saying it know that it's
a lie jack turbine knows that it's a lie
and he knows it's a lie we know it's a
lie to start with because we only just
started recently giving these drugs to
physically healthy children
there aren't any reliable long-term
studies because there couldn't be
this current crop of children are the
lab rats the guinea pigs the canaries in
the pharmaceutical coal mine whatever
imagery you want to use
gender affirmation care is quote unquote
gender affirmation care so-called is
experimental
the medical industry is experimenting on
kids and making billions doing it
but we do know a few things about
puberty blockers we know that these are
drugs interfering with the normal
healthy processes in the body
we know that they intentionally stunt
growth that's what they're designed to
do or sorry not designed to do let me
clarify that
they were not designed for this purpose
at all they weren't designed to be used
by kids in the first place
they're being used off-label but we do
know that they stunt growth that's that
we know for a fact
and in fact you can even go to
mainstream sources like the mayo clinic
hardly a right-wing publication
and you'll be told plain as day that the
long-term effects of puberty blockers
and there are long-term effects
potentially include stunting of growth
uh they can affect a child's bone
density permanently they can make
children sterile permanently
that's why the nhs website used to
assure that assure us that plot puberty
blockers are temporary and reversible it
used to say that now it doesn't
now this is what it says on the nhs
website it says little is known about
the long-term side effects of hormone or
puberty blockers in children with gender
dysphoria it's also not known whether
hormone blockers affect the development
of the teenage brain or children's bones
side effects may also include hot
flashes fatigue and mood alterations
from the age of 16 teenagers who've been
on hormone blockers for at least 12
months
may be given cross-sex hormones also
known as gender affirming hormones these
hormones cause some irreversible changes
such as breast development caused by
taking estrogen breaking
breaking or deepening of the voice
long-term cross-sex hormone treatment
may cause temporary or even permanent
infertility
temporary and reversible
we're told right
if by temporary and reversible you mean
that your child after taking these drugs
will forever be a physically
underdeveloped sterile adult with
brittle bones who will never have
children
and that's just the start of the
long-term effects long-term effects that
by the way he cannot possibly choose
to fall victim to
these is a child who can't possibly know
what any of that means he can't
you could say to a child well you know
if you take this
uh hey listen little uh 12 year old if
you take this um
in the future you might not you know you
might not be able to have kids
it doesn't mean anything to a 12 year
old
no 12 year old especially no 12 year old
boy
wants to have kids it's not anywhere on
their radar
so they're choosing to forego they're
making permanent decisions for their for
their lives
decisions that will profoundly
impact the rest of their lives and they
cannot possibly know what they're
getting themselves into or what they're
giving up
which includes by the way puberty itself
okay
when you say to a child oh do you want
to block your puberty
what hey do you want to go through
puberty or not
what does that mean to them they don't
even know what it is they haven't gone
through it
now when you lie to them and you tell
them listen some there could be some
changes in your body that are happening
pretty soon it's going to be
uncomfortable uh you could just put that
off if you want it'll it'll be no
problem at all just take this magic pill
here and you're gonna put off those
changes and you're gonna have to change
go through the changes later in life
well that's that's nonsense but they're
not gonna know that
and there are many other terrible
effects that we know about with the with
these drugs and many that we don't
because nobody has ever done this to
children before
we're the first to do it
this is historic and unprecedented in
all the worst ways
but
it will work out
pretty well for big pharma
and apparently that's a great
consolation to the left as it turns out
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
if you're a parent then you know kids
are amazing
and expensive and also sometimes frankly
a little bit annoying but when it comes
to the expensive thing it's especially
the case with fabric protecting your
family with term life insurance is
surprisingly affordable fabric was built
specifically for parents to help you
manage your family's financial future
like a parenting pro stress free fabrics
new lower prices mean significant
savings over other providers with great
policies like a million dollars in
coverage for less than a dollar a day
everything is on your schedule with
fabric because it's all online less than
10 minutes to apply and you could be
offered coverage instantly with no
health exam required then just
personalize your quote to fit your
family's needs with fabrics online hub
it's easy to track your family finances
all in one place get affordable life
insurance set up your kids college
savings plans and even establish a rainy
day savings fund planning for the future
has never been easier there's no risk to
apply today fabric has a 30-day
money-back guarantee and you can cancel
at any time protect your family with
term life insurance now in just 10
minutes apply today at meatfabric.com
walsh that's meat fabric dot com slash
walsh to start protecting your family
today m-e-e-t fabric dot com slash walsh
fabric insurance agency policies issued
by vantislife not available in new york
and montana prices subject to under
writing and health questions
uh i want to mention this right at the
top because i wanted to put it into the
opening and uh i didn't have time to
include it there so
just on on this issue of puberty
blockers which are supposedly um
benign reversible temporary according to
jack turbine and the jack turbines of
the world and again i don't want you to
think that jack turbin although he is
unfortunately a very influential voice
in this world
um i want you to think that he's an
outlier he's a no this is this is this
is the narrative this is the official
narrative that parents are being told
that kids are being told this is what
you hear from if you go into your gender
affirming therapy this is what you're
going to hear about temporary reversible
um
puberty blockers well
here's
a here's this is something that was put
on the on the trans forum on reddit
and um it was posted by a parent this is
by the way post about four years ago and
it sat there online and nobody really
noticed it and over the weekend um
someone on twitter found this on reddit
and posted the screenshot and now if you
go to reddit to read the original post
it's been taken down
so the moderators over at the transform
on reddit
have taken it down because they don't
want you to see this
but this was from a parent
who was
soliciting help
and this is what it says
i'll read it to you
i have no clue what to do daughter can't
get the bottom surgery as becoming
suicidal
uh then it says i've always been in
support of my transgender daughter when
she was still a boy and started
expressing a want to be a girl
i did everything right
therapists then puberty blockers
everything well we could just pause
there and say uh that is not doing
everything right that actually is you
every step of the way doing everything
wrong
and hurting your child
so that's not everything right it's it's
you
based on this quick
summation
you did literally nothing right
okay you you faced a fork in the road
and um one after another and you went in
the wrong direction every single time
um it continues now she's 20 and
everything is falling apart we had to
hold off on the body surgery because of
cost but now finally had enough and went
and got several consults all have said
the same thing the puberty blockers have
left her with a micro penis
she has to get part of her vagina made
with her colon well one of her friends
had that surgery and even years later it
smells fairly colon-like
so this is what they're doing with to
young people
they're using parts of their internal
organs to make
fake vaginas
on
on young men
obviously my daughter is now distraught
she's in counseling but is becoming
worse and worse in her mental state and
i'm frantic on top of this she has never
had any sexual function no urges no
erections even when she tried
masturbation to see if she could
stimulate herself nothing the doctors
say this may not uh change even after
the surgery
her dating life is dismal as well we
knew it would be hard but it's
impossible the one man who was with her
for a while soon just became frustrated
by her lack of sexual anything and broke
it off i don't know what to do a friend
suggested i post here for advice please
help me help my child well
the tragic reality here is that um
there is no good answer
now the absolute wrong answer would be
to go through with any kind of surgery
whatsoever
but um there's no great answer
because you're because of what you have
done to your child
and now he is going to live with the
consequences for the rest of his life
so what happened is that he as a child
with your facilitation
gave up on manhood gave up on
masculinity before he'd even ex really
experienced it
gave up it made it he made a decision
he didn't make the decision
you you made the decision and the
doctors made the decision
for him
about his future self
of course the future self has no has no
say in the matter
um
and so now he's he's never going to be a
woman that's never going to happen
but also physically he's
not a fully developed man so he's he's
but he's still male
biologically and always will be
but in terms of physically and how he
appears he's just kind of stuck in this
in this limp this purgatory
and this is the fate of so many kids
they're going to be languishing forever
in this kind of gender purgatory
where they don't really look anymore
like their actual true selves but
they'll never be
the this
the fantasy version that they're trying
to attain
but isn't that interesting too also
because uh we just heard from dr jack
turbin about there are no long-term side
effects everything is reversible
well here we we hear this from a parent
micro penis
no sexual function whatsoever
oh yeah that's the other thing that's
those are those are the other long-term
side effects that don't exist according
to jack turbin and his ilk
is that um not only
are you looking at being sterile as an
adult but you may have no
sexual function
no libido at all no sexual desires
so we have kids
who are choosing but not really choosing
because because they can't
a sterile
sexless adulthood
and they're gonna have to live with that
forever
temporary universal it's just a lie
um okay let's start with this says new
york for this in the new york post says
a dolphin that washed up on a florida
beach was found to have been stabbed to
death in a sick marine murder that
investigators are now trying to solve
beachgoers discovered the remains of the
female bottlenose dolphin with a gory
gash above its right eye late last month
along the shoreline
the national oceanic and atmospheric
administration conducted an uh
uh necropsy
on the mammal and determined that it had
been impaled with a spear-like object
this injury was sustained while it was a
live official said the agency said the
dolphin was likely being illegally fed
in a semi-upright position before being
stabbed
and now um
federal officials are looking into this
and uh there could be a year in prison
for the person who stabbed the dolphin
and a hundred thousand dollar fine
all right well
let me just say to start with if i have
to clarify this i am definitely 100
opposed to stabbing dolphins i do not i
do not support that at all so whoever
stabbed this dolphin
uh and you want to give him a fine send
him to prison
okay i'm fine with that
um
but i just can't help anytime i see a
story like this i can't help but note
the contrast
and especially because now we're talking
about federal officials talk about a
federal crime
and so i see the contrast here we've got
a dead dolphin on a beach that's been
stabbed in the in the head
and they do an autopsy
even though i think it's pretty clear
how the dolphin died but they did an
autopsy and now they've got federal
officials that are going to go hunt down
the perpetrator of this crime and bring
them to just throw the book at them
whatever they can
contrast that with what happened in dc
a few weeks ago
where you had fully developed infant
babies
uh five of them who were found dead
in a in a you know in a container that
was taken from an abortion clinic
and they also had head wounds but in
this case their their uh a gash in their
their skulls had been gashed open and
their brain sucked out
and in that case
um even though there is a lot of
evidence that a federal crime was
committed
partial birth abortion is a federal
crime
no autopsy was performed and no federal
investigation and there will be no
penalties whatsoever for the perpetrator
and also the other thing is in that case
we we know who did it
it's an abortionist santangelo in town
we know we you we know where he is we
know where he works
so they could just march over there
tomorrow and arrest them on federal
crimes and they're not going to do it
so a a dead dolphin attracts the
attention of federal officials in our
federal government but not dead babies
and i say this and please and i brought
this up i pointed this out on twitter
and i had all these dummies who were
responding in the comments well you know
we could be outraged about both it's
possible to be outraged by both men yeah
i know
that first of all i'm not just talking
about outrage here
i'm talking about criminal penalties
and the federal government has decided
that only one of these perpetrators the
person who killed dolphins is going to
face penalties
while the person who killed the babies
will not so it's not just about outrage
it's about crimes being done and
punishments for those crimes
but also in terms of outrage yeah i i
you know i i couldn't help but note all
the people tweeting about the dead
dolphin
and of course i didn't look into it i
didn't check but i i think you and i
both know that
a great number of the people who are
outraged by the dead dolphin said
nothing at all about the dead babies
um and so yes while it's possible to be
outraged by both the fact is
that many americans are not outraged by
both really they're only outraged by one
and that's the dead dolphin
and even if you are outraged by both
your outrage about the dead
children should should
be
overwhelmingly
um
you know more severe than your outrage
over the dead dolphin
like they don't even belong in the same
conversation at all
a dead dolphin that's the kind of thing
you hear about that and you say well
that's uh you know that's too bad that's
that's that's really
who stabs a dolphin
i i hope they find the person who did
like that's that's all you got to say
about the dolphin
but
what happened these children should
provoke within you
a an intense fiery
rage like at the bottom of your right
down to the bottom of your soul you
should feel that rage
and if you don't
and instead you feel it over the dolphin
then there is something sick within you
there's there's something wrong with you
and you're not the only one if that's
any consolation
because we live in a society that
conditions people to
value
animal life over human life
laws have consequences
and that's one of them
there are the practical consequences of
laws like it determines who goes to jail
who suffers penalties
but also it it it has it has a
consequences at a deeper level
where if you live in a in a country
where it's illegal to kill dolphins
and if you kill a dolphin the federal
government's going to come after you
but it's not illegal to kill babies for
a lot of people after a while that's
going to condition them they're going to
because they live in this environment
they are after a while going to see
the
dolphin as more valuable than the baby
um
and that's the
fact of the matter i mean
dolphins
in america
have more legal rights
than
young babies
they have more legal rights
according to the law they are worth more
according to the law
than babies
all right we mentioned elon musk before
the
left is still in the midst of its of its
meltdown uh over this and here was an
msnbc segment with um
al sharpton
who still somehow has a show on msnbc
that i guess some people watch i don't
know how they could keep this show going
if nobody watched it i can't imagine can
you imagine sitting down for an hour and
choosing to watch al sharpton i can't
some people do though and here's what
they had to say about elon musk
tesla ceo
uh musk who has made a 43 billion dollar
offer for twitter to quote build an
arena for free speech
musk has accused twitter of censoring
his users are you concerned that what
musk is trying to do is to open up the
platform for more misinformation about
topics such as covert 19 and the 2020
election and perhaps even allow former
president trump to get his account back
i mean i'm going to be honest elon musk
is a danger to twitter and to freedom of
speech he has been known to say some of
the most transphobic and homophobic
things to his millions of followers so
creating an arena for hate to me that's
what that sounds like an opportunity for
him to have no consequences to have no
flags for people just to be able to do
whatever it is and say whatever they
want with regardless of what kind of
harm that it causes so i think that this
is something that folks really need to
be paying attention to because i think
that elon musk buying twitter or
creating this quote unquote arena
would be problematic did al sharpton
just give elon musk a gender transition
it sounds like he said ilana musk
i could be wrong and that's maybe that
that's one way that elon musk could
solve all this this this problem for
himself he just rebranded himself to
elana musk had a gender transition came
out as a woman
you know he's trans now he's already an
african-american immigrant that that
that apparently hasn't hasn't helped too
much um
in the uh
in the court of public opinion but if he
was a tr i mean if he was a trans
african-american immigrant
then come on he's got way too many
victim points at that at that point you
have to just let him take twitter um
she says that the guest there says that
elon musk is a danger to twitter
and to free speech
now on the first
note she's
she's she's right actually
he is a danger to twitter as it is
currently
assembled
he is a danger to twitter as it is as it
currently functions
he's certainly a danger to the to
twitter's corrupt board
um he's a danger in that way but that's
that's that's a good thing
that's called being he's another way of
putting us he's a he's an actual
disrupter
and a lot of people get credit
for being disruptors who aren't but in
this case that's actually what what elon
musk is
and she also says that he's a danger to
free speech and it's a little confusing
to follow the logic here because
she says he's a danger to free speech
because
he would turn
twitter into an arena where you could
say whatever you want
no matter how much it hurts people's
feelings
well hold on a second
he's a danger to free speech because
he'll allow people to say whatever they
want
that doesn't seem to make any sense at
all does it
and and in fact it doesn't and the
reason why it doesn't make any sense and
it's totally incoherent and all of our
conversations really about anything uh
descend so quickly into incoherence is
that
you know the framework for the
conversation
we're starting from a faulty premise
and in this case the faulty premise is
that everybody cares about free speech
which they don't
maybe there would be some chance of us
having
you know a debate
some kind of productive debate in this
country
if everybody was just honest from the
beginning about what they actually want
and what they believe
so on the left
they don't care at all about free speech
so just say that
you know
make your argument against free speech
i'm not going to going to agree with it
but that's your argument
rather than arguing against free speech
within the context of pretending that
you're trying to defend free speech well
there's just no hope of anything
happening there
no hope of us understanding each other
so for the msnbc panelist there her
actual view is that free speech is bad
and she doesn't think we should have it
we should not be able to just say
whatever we want
and okay start that's your starting
point
make your case
i'll listen to that at least because
this i can't listen to
i'm not going to listen to you pretend
that um
you're trying to protect free speech by
abolishing it that doesn't make any
sense
but if you could make some kind of at
least coherent
uh robust argument against free speech
i'll at least i'll listen to you
you're gonna have a hard time convincing
me but i'll i will listen
all right um chris coons is a senator
from delaware and he is uh
calling on the u.s
to get involved and stop russia and if
that means a world war then it sounds
like he's perfectly willing to
um endure that or at least have the rest
of us indoors it's not going to affect
him much let's listen to that
in some public remarks this week you
said um
the country needs to talk about when it
might be willing to send troops to
ukraine you said if the answer is never
then we are inviting another level of
escalation and brutality by putin are
you arguing that president biden was
wrong when he said he would not send
troops to ukraine are you asking him to
set a red line
margaret i think those of us in congress
who have a critical role in setting
foreign policy
and in advising
the president in terms of his decisions
as commander-in-chief
need to look clearly uh at the level of
brutality this is a moment of enormous
challenge for all of us
and i deeply respect president biden's
leadership in pulling together the west
in imposing crushing sanctions
on russia and in bringing to this fight
countries that had stayed on the
sidelines before i think president
biden's leadership has been steady and
constructive but this is a critical
moment if vladimir putin who has shown
us how brutal he can be is allowed to
just continue uh to massacre civilians
to commit war crimes um throughout
ukraine without nato without the west
coming more forcefully to his aid
i great i i deeply
worry that what's going to happen next
is that we will see ukraine turn into
syria the american people cannot turn
away from this tragedy in ukraine i
think the history of the 21st century
turns on how fiercely we defend freedom
in ukraine and that putin will only stop
when we stop him
defend uh yeah we need to go to war to
defend freedom in uh in ukraine you
notice how the argument has shifted
quite a bit because in the uh you know
early on early in in putin's invasion of
ukraine
we were told that well we might have to
get involved uh we might have to get
involved and stop it because if we don't
there were all these comparisons to
world war ii right and hitler and uh
look what happened when the west didn't
rise up to put a stop to
to hitler's campaign of invasion early
on um
and so that was that was the argument in
the first few weeks i mean up until like
it seems like just 15 seconds ago that's
what they were telling us that we don't
we got to get involved potentially
because if we don't then putin's gonna
he's gonna keep going and he's gonna in
continue his invasion and pretty much
pretty soon is going to occupy all of
europe like that's that's where this is
going to head
and they've um
they've stepped back from that
because it's very clear with the way
this is playing out that's not going to
happen
like
the issue here is ukraine
um it's not putin continuing on and next
thing you know he's uh he's in france
like that we know that they can't make
that argument anymore that was always
absurd to begin with it's even more
absurd now
and so now it is it is all about
ukraine itself
they're not pretending that going to war
to protect ukraine is somehow an act of
self-defense on our part right not
pretending that anymore
now it is uh well we can't turn away
from the atrocities in ukraine all these
terrible things are happening with the
fight for freedom
and i don't deny that terrible things
are happening and it is it is a terrible
situation i want the war to be i wish it
never started i want it to be over as
soon as possible
i'm not sure you know sending weapons
over there and any other resources we
send i'm not sure how
that
will bring about a situation where the
war is going to end sooner it seems like
that's just going to prolong it so i
want to see the war end because it's a
terrible thing
but do we have to go to war to defend
the freedom of ukraine
um
americans american families
should they american parents should they
send their children overseas
to die for the sake of the freedom of
ukraine the answer to that is no
all right um
let's see one other thing i wanted to
mention this is from fox news a
pennsylvania candidate for the u.s house
has been open about her past as a
part-time stripper in college and her
decision to get an abortion when she was
18. well she's running as a democrat so
of course she's open about that those
that's just that's that's a resume
builder right there stripper she had an
abortion
um
she uh also has an only fans now of
course in a may 2021 video she posted
twitter hunt describes what led her to
get an abortion a decade ago she's now
running to unseat incumbent democratic
representative dwight evans in the
primary election she raised nearly 328
000 in the first quarter of 2022
and uh so maybe she'll be a formidable
opponent but here she is a couple years
ago explaining why she had that abortion
there are a few reasons including
climate change by the way let's listen
when i was 18 i was part of the two
percent of
people who can get pregnant on birth
control and i found out i was pregnant
and i decided that i was not ready to
bring a child into this world
and i decided to get an abortion
uh
that decision was made with a lot of
love i think that being pro-life is
being pro-choice
and that
the i've
i
as a person was not ready to bring a
child into this world but also the world
was not in a state and is not 10 years
later is not in a state that i wanted to
bring a child into yet which is my
decision uh to make uh we have a lack of
jobs my generation faces a lack of jobs
a lack of living wage a housing crisis
an affordable housing crisis a student
debt crisis the climate emergency the
prison industrial complex
uh
and the the list goes on and on and i i
wanted to be able to offer my child
better
it's like what i just said about free
speech like let's just just start being
honest with yourself and with us
rather than saying you got an abortion
because you love your child so your
child deserves better
than uh what the world has to offer so
instead you're just gonna kill him
right it's it's not like you can kill
your child and then
wait for the world to get better
which is never going to happen because
we we live in a in a fallen world and
there's always going to be pain and
suffering in the world so but you can't
do that wait for the world to magically
get better and then have that same kid
later
or the timing is right no that that
child is dead forever
and so that of course doesn't make any
sense and rather than trying to position
abortion this way it's something i did
it for the sake of the child i killed my
child for his own sake it was a loving
act
just start from from a point of honesty
and say i i don't
i didn't care about this this person
this is all about me
why should i have to make sacrifices
for him
that's not a defensible position but
that's the honest position start there
at least
and she throws it all in there uh
climate change the prison industrial
complex
you know the great thing about that is
that if you are a good mother which i
you know i understand as a
stripper and someone only fans maybe
that's a lot to ask but if you're a good
parent then you don't really have to
worry too much about the prison
industrial complex for your as far as
your own kid is concerned that's what
that's what because you're going to
raise them so that they don't end up
going to prison
and that's going to work like 95 percent
of the time if you're just a good parent
your kid's not going to end up in prison
but it's all it all is in the end is a
is a loving
kill a child because you love them
absolutely perverse let's get now to the
comment section
[Music]
tom d says i came here through shapiro
and crowder i'm a conservative but i
draw the line here mr walsh is too
extreme for my liking
i i totally agree i'm i'm a scary person
and very extreme you should probably
stay far far away from me
um
let's see
although those other two characters that
you mentioned they're pretty extreme
right wing lunatics as well so i don't
know
um
let's see your point that this proves we
are run by oligarchs it's spot on when
the constitution can't protect our
rights yet some billionaire can
we are flat-out effed
unless we act
and jeff says i cannot tell you how much
i enjoy you calling elon musk an
african-american immigrant i think i
enjoy it as much as you enjoy saying it
well i hope you enjoy
me saying it because
that joke is not going away for as long
as elon musk is in the news and i think
he's gonna be in the news for you know
quite some time
um
courtney says uh daily cancellation i
agree my husband took a lower paying job
so he could be more present at home
instead of working 68 hours a week he
works 40 to 50 and comes home early
sometimes helps me with with the kids
and house work is life
i think they mean work fund balance
trying to teach our kids to do the hard
work first then the fun stuff and that's
an important distinction too because i
talk about how work is life life work is
life life is work i mean both of those
things are true
that's not to say that your job
is life or that your life is your job
yes your your life should be quite a bit
bigger than your nine to five job
whatever that might be
but there are other forms of of work
like if you're a stay-at-home mom you
don't have a job but you do work
and that's why there's this argument
sometimes about oh does being a
stay-at-home mom does it count as a job
is it a real job well no it's not a it's
not a job you don't clock in you don't
get paid for it's not a job it's work
though
see a job is just one form of work
and the point about life is that no
matter how you slice it
work is required
in order to sustain your existence
the only difference is that now in the
modern western society
you actually have the option to not do
any of that work or not do most of it
and kind of conscript someone else to do
it for you
and in fact in in older times that
option existed as well in a different
form
let's see michael says matt have you
slash will you see father stew how do
you feel about faith-based films with
profanity the movie has an r rating for
language i personally feel there's never
an excuse for profanity
in a movie i haven't seen the movie yet
i know what you're talking about this is
the mark wahlberg movie with mel gibson
and uh it's a
true story about a
guy who i think is like an ex-con and he
comes out of this hard life and he
eventually becomes a priest
and i've heard
it's getting panned by the critics so
you go to rod tomatoes it's one of those
classic things where it's got like a 30
rotten score from the critics and then
98 of the audience likes it so
that for a movie like this i would
actually be any movie that involves
faith christianity the church
if it's critically acclaimed that makes
me very nervous
um so the fact that critics hate it is a
real good sign for me
and uh mark wahlberg and mel gibson are
both excellent so i am interested i'll
probably watch it i i have also heard
about the profanity i've heard these
complaints because it's it's actually
it's
may appear to be a quote unquote
faith-based film based on the the uh
the content the subject matter and some
of the people involved
but it's got a lot of harsh language and
so it actually has an r rating
how do i feel about that i
i think that's a good thing actually
because that's that's real that's
reality you're trying to tell a story
about something real something that
actually happened
and you want people to be able to
understand it and relate to it and get
invested in the story
and so how could you possibly tell a
story about an ex-con a guy who
lived this hard life into drugs and
whatever else
and there's never any profanity
but he gets mad at someone and you hear
him say oh gosh darn you big meany head
like the minute i hear that it takes me
out of the story it's not real
and so what you have to ask yourself is
not whether there should be profanity in
the movie it's whether this is a story
worth telling and of course it's a story
worth a story of redemption
so yeah in fact you do you do need
harsh language you do need uh cussing in
movies sometimes because it's real
remember that was one of my big
complaints about um
what's that the football movie with
denzel washington remember the titans
okay which is like a good movie
and um
it's got denzel washington's a football
movie but it's it's pg
and so you've got all these scenes in a
locker room with these high school kids
and the football players and they're
arguing they're fighting and everything
and uh but it's only pg language that
they use and it just makes it ridiculous
and it takes you out of the story
so i think that's great uh let's see
another one says pk star storm says uh
matt matt echoing the incredibles 2
villain monologue during the
cancellation segment lol
well i've never seen the incredibles 2 i
don't plan on seeing it but i do find
that i very often agree
somewhat
with the villains in superhero movies
like on the rare occasion when i watch a
superhero movie and i and i hear the
villain and we get to his big
speech at the end
oftentimes i listen to it i think he's
got a point
maybe that's why i can't get into the
genre because they're too hard on the
super villains i relate to them too much
i don't know what that says about me
you know americans used to turn to
sports to get away from politics but the
left has now made that impossible
turning them into a stage for virtue
signals and political actors and nba
star jonathan isaac isn't having it
isaac faced heavy criticism for the
media for his views on social issues and
vaccines over the past few years and he
still stood strong which is why i'm
extremely excited to announce that he's
decided to write a book with the daily
wire called why i stand jonathan's book
will be about the rise of his basketball
career his journey into faith and his
strength to stand alone in the face of
immense pressure the book is available
for pre-order now at amazon so reserve
your copy today now let's get to our
daily cancellation
[Music]
over easter weekend a video went viral
which sparked perhaps a stronger
reaction than you might expect that is
you might not have expected the strong
reaction if you've been cryogenically
frozen for the past half century and
were just thought out and introduced to
the internet 30 seconds ago but anybody
with a bit more experience in cyberspace
knows that literally anything sparks a
strong reaction especially anything
involving politics religion or airplanes
if you combine the three you've got a
real powder keg on your hands not
literally we hope that brings us to this
video which shows a
a group of people on a flight standing
up and singing christian worship music
on the flight one of them is standing in
the aisle with an acoustic guitar
we know that that man with the guitar is
named jack jens jr he's a pastor and the
founder of uh kingdom realm ministries
it's called he and his crew were
traveling across europe and into ukraine
apparently over the past few weeks we
know all of this because the media has
published some not so favorable stories
about this incident and jen's has
actually been doxxed on twitter by the
outrage mob
some prominent people have joined the
backlash such as ilhan omar who tweeted
on saturday quote
i think my family and i should have a
prayer session next time i'm on a plane
how do you think it will end
yeah some people uh play music on a
plane
ilhan wasn't even there
and yet she has found a way to make
herself the victim of it
ilhan is good at playing this game it's
like six degrees of kevin bacon except
except uh instead of connecting an actor
to kevin bacon she's able to connect any
event in the world to her own personal
victimhood narrative
it's almost impressive but before we
address ilhan's claims in any more
detail let's first watch
the controversial video in question
[Music]
now let me just say up front that um i
could very much relate to the bald guy
in the foreground staring helplessly
into the camera you could see him right
there
uh
some of the passengers seem to be
relatively pleased with the performance
but i i think i'd be reacting more
like that guy right there
this would be in many ways like this
situation for me would be my personal
help i appreciate the message of the
song
but i really personally
from an aesthetic standpoint cannot
stand acoustic youth pastor christian
music
the idea of being trapped in a metal
tube 30 000 feet in the air with a guy
strumming his guitar two feet from my
eardrums is traumatizing to think about
if i was in an exit row i might consider
making a break for it this is almost as
bad as somebody eating an onion bagel in
the seat right next to you an experience
that i've suffered through on more than
one occasion
in those cases with respect to the bagel
chompers i think it'd be legally and
morally justifiable for the air marshal
to just escort the offender off of the
plane in the middle of the flight
i would not advocate for the same
penalty for the worship team in the
video because at least their hearts are
in the right place
but i do think
that you should just give people a
choice before subjecting them to
contemporary christian folk music
consent is key i mean i'm christian and
i don't even like it
you can't just assume that everybody
wants to hear that i mean what if
somebody stood up in the aisle and
started yodeling
what if a polka band played accordion
music all the way over the atlantic
what if god forbid beyonce was on the
flight and started singing a cappella i
mean where does it end
my problem is with the singing then not
with the message
but for ilhan omar and the others in the
online outrage are great brigade it's
the opposite
that's why none of these people
complained when the cast of the lion
king sang the circle of life on a plane
in australia let's watch that again
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
my god it's an epidemic
imagine being a stuck being stuck in a
plane with that i that's again my my
nightmare i'm on i'm already on a plane
and then the plane turns into high
school musical that's i cannot and i
would rather i just i'd want to be dead
and yet if i bring my kids on a plane
and they make a noise louder than a
whisper everyone in the surrounding rows
will turn around and give us icy glares
of death like god forbid your kid make
any sound at all
and yet these people could turn the
whole flight into a broadway performance
that strikes me as a double standard
meanwhile ilhan omar is looking for a
different double standard she says that
she and her family you know if they
prayed on a plane people would get upset
well first of all given that omar
married her brother
prayer is certainly not the most
upsetting thing that omar does with her
family second
i don't need to speculate about what
would happen if muslims prayed on a
plane i was just recently on an 18-hour
qatar airways flight to and from africa
muslim prayer is so common on those
flights that they actually put the
coordinates to mecca up on the seat back
screens to help facilitate it
on many flights around the muslim world
they'll actually play an islamic prayer
over the the intercom before takeoff
muslims are not shy about expressing
their faith loudly and publicly
many mosques including in the united
states will play the
islamic call to prayer over loudspeakers
throughout the day so that the whole
town can hear it
and what if any white person were to
complain about any of that
what if i had whined about the muslim
prayer on my guitar flight
what what if someone who lived near a
mosque said that they didn't want to
hear the muslim call to prayer
how would ilhan omar respond to that
well we all know she'd rush to the scene
and start vomiting words like bigotry
and islamophobia all over the place
she's searching for a double standard
but all she needs to do is look in the
mirror she's the one with the double
standard as usual
now you might point out that the muslim
prayer on flights
generally happens in and around heavily
muslim areas of the world fair enough
but the west is heavily christian not as
much as it used to be not as much as it
should be but still predominantly
christian according to any survey i've
ever seen on the subject so it's the
same old story here ilhan omar
does not believe that anything in the
west should reflect the west's dominant
historical culture and religion
the middle east is allowed to wear its
muslim culture with pride but the west
cannot do the same with its historical
christian culture according to omar
ilhan omar
was born in somalia which is one of the
worst places on earth it is an absolute
hellhole it's a wasteland a failed state
her family fled that place sought refuge
here and they were welcomed with open
arms
and yet she despises her adopted home
the christian west took her in elected
her to congress made her one of the most
influential people in the country and
still she has no gratitude she has no
love for the place that saved her life
or for the place
uh or or for the people who inhabit that
place
she came into this culture our culture
and immediately decided that the culture
must change
not just change but be entirely
dismantled and rebuilt to reflect her
own ideology and priorities and if you
think that the last statement there is
reading a little bit too much into her
complaining about people singing
christian songs on a flight you'd be
right but i'm not reading that into her
reaction to the flight video i'm
actually just quoting her directly let's
listen to that
as long as our economy
and political systems prioritize private
without considering who is profiting
who is being shut out
we will perpetuate this inequality
so we cannot stop at criminal justice
system
we must begin the work of dismantling
the whole system of oppression wherever
we find it
dismantle the whole system
gets here from somalia wants to
dismantle it all
and you know she's coming from a country
that is entirely dismantled where all
the systems are dismantled
so you think she would have had her fill
of that by now
so the reason why her complaints about
the christians on the flight rub some of
us the wrong way is that it's consistent
with a long-established theme
and that theme is omar's lack of
gratitude
and that in fact is a much broader theme
that encompasses more than just ilhan
omar we don't inculcate or encourage
gratitude in any of the people who we
accept into our country
or any of the people born here naturally
that's the underlying issue goes a lot
deeper than what she said about people
singing on a plane and it's for this
deeper underlying reason that ilhan omar
is today probably not for the first time
and certainly not for the last cancelled
and we'll leave it there for today
thanks for watching thanks for listening
have a great day godspeed
[Music]
the matt wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover production manager pavo valdoski
our associate producer is mckenna waters
the show is edited by robbie dantzler
our audio is mixed by mike coromina and
hair and makeup is done by cherokee
heart the matt wall show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 22.
twitter triggers a poison pill to stop
elon musk's hostile takeover president
trump endorses jd vance in ohio and
white house press secretary jen saki
refers to a reporter as a stupid sob
what a threat on the media and
journalism we will cover all of it on
the michael knowles show